you
it's Jerry I am on Leech s org playing a
ooh playing a five-o game you know I had
a seek out for for two and I think I
accidentally clicked on a five-o game so
we're gonna go with the five-o game so I
can't lean on increment all right let's
try Bishop d3 I don't know
eeny meeny miny moe I want a staff ac4
okay so they're gonna go hunting let's
scoop up the bishop here
and I saw that that was a possibility I
[Music]
guess will develop first Bishop here
it certainly intensified the pressure on
d4 and they're doing just that take
right back okay so how do things stand
here the early stage um still happy mmm
better pond presence in the center so is
black valuing the night a bit more than
my light square bishop maybe uh can I
try to preserve the bishop now let's try
to preserve the bishop maybe I uh gain a
valuable temple against the night I
could certainly grab some Tempe against
my bishop so so much for this talk about
staying off of the C 4 square ooh maybe
on second thought I have to backtrack
this poem could get a little bit excited
about chasing my night away and winning
this pawn that's a bit mysterious okay
let's get here
maybe this pawn falls one day already
how many times do I want to move with
this bishop am i asking for trouble if I
go here maybe gets trapped playing with
fire if I do that oh how about this move
yeah I like this one threaten this pawn
and maybe threaten to preserve my bishop
now make up your mind already Knight
takes I have a choice I'll keep this
file opened I'm defending you for
throwing a punch here let's just
centralize
I don't want to play f3 too soon
weakens in Chi three so maybe I actually
am threatening like out here maybe d5 so
let's maybe thing forward
so I'll here here now I'm gonna go back
cover this so that on this push I could
take at least I don't want to give up
two rooks for the Queen
so how are we doing on the clock I'm a
little bit behind
okaycome there do I make some progress
maybe we go here as a start Queen is
unprotected so maybe I'm introducing a
night move to one of these two maybe on
second thought it was known on b5 I
could take I saying thinking before
Queen see for maybe a four okay so
they're out of a pin may be preparing to
expand maybe now is the time to do this
now that the Queen yeah let's give this
a go
something here so
here I could do that okay this time so
are they're gonna take first okay I
guess it's it's going to open up in the
end okay so they're going to play with
an isolated pawn Oh interesting
rook takes rook rook takes rook
or do I just take the night first I'm
gonna say let's want to take the night
first let's see if they want to do they
might take on you honored here okay only
one move so they were not taking with
the rook interesting
and I don't want B to to fall I gotta go
quicker tell you what I'll go here you
take the beep on I get h6 I think this
is important one - hang on - okay
go back home this defends b2 weakens f5
I'd like to get these two moves in if I
can let's start with this here I could
come here I don't know is this problem
going to get traded given an opportunity
I'm going to play here offering a queen
exchange interesting and hitting a 2 huh
well I don't have much choice do I
that's a nice move I'm gonna look super
passive but I do not like the idea of
fixing a black pawn in this light square
so I know it enables this trading of the
isolated pawn but I'm kind of banking on
the fact that maybe Bishop III is strong
huh here's a plunder okay
have to go here that
too strong so I have absolutely nothing
I'm gonna try to maybe show that this
King is a little bit vulnerable that's
the only thing I have going for me is a
better King side structure way down on
the clock
gotta watch out for Forks these guys are
on the same rank he setting some tricky
stuff up on d1 so let's rule that out
for starters maybe I just backup and
consolidate a little bit do I want to
sneak in another move
seems really passive immediately yes
alright I'm gonna try something like
this can I just get a little bit active
just a little bit wanna go in a pac-man
mode Wow
fearless opponent is definitely fearless
and they're dropping upon happy about
that I'm up upon all of a sudden 53
seconds clean is defending here I just
wanted to crawl up into a ball like this
defend my base point um I guess here
keep pressure on a couple things there's
no way for I have a check here how do I
activate my rook can you can you give me
a square let me have a new square for my
King there's also this check I should be
aware of maybe King here where's the
Queen go you can't go too far has a
responsibility to funding both pawns is
this really an improvement who would
know okay Queen there let's give it a
check another check I'm thinking I have
time gainers I don't have time gainers
well right here is where I want to be I
need a different a role reversal I need
to get my rook doing something okay I'll
scoop this one up first 22 ticks
check aroni even though the Queen's off
it's gonna be a difficult task ahead
let's go here it's tough 14 seconds back
a minute huh
hmm now I am wishing head increment
they're in their pen they're gonna see
that all right can we consolidate and my
rook finally moved from f1 any closer I
should get to b1 b1 that's where I want
to be trade I might have had something
different there five seconds
what kind of magic can I work with here
that's probably a drawer
upon hitting or is it no I win this not
a lot of time
you
Wow oh man I'm uh I can't talk for a
moment I'm trying to my heartbeats
racing that's what happens in time
scrambles I'm just slowing my heartbeat
down well that that's why that's why I
don't want to play uh that's why I
wanted the increment it's too stressful
okay let's see what to note with this
one if I floundered a lot in the
beginning a lot of floundering it's it's
it's pretty much an equal position right
around here the light square bishop was
clueless
and what should I maybe do a little bit
different whoo right around here there's
got to be a better middle game plan
maybe I should be thinking forward some
more I was fish up here let me just go
into the analysis straight away not turn
on the engine just out Bishop d4 is this
really a great bother d5
I'm not a fan of this I don't know I'd
have to go here and then my pieces start
getting shoved around maybe this isn't
actually maybe this isn't so bad
no no no III should be okay with this
structure yes because if given this is
not a bother cuz my night is improved
and then I could even chip away at this
so I shouldn't be too afraid of this
structural change so I'm not saying
black has to play this but you know
comparing the bishop locations this is
more aggressive in what I would love to
have happen here is a dark square bishop
exchange and keep it Queen and night on
ideally maybe I could do something
exciting on f6 or h6 these are the two
pieces that could capitalize on these
weak squares so I should I should have
been I think at least I should have went
with Bishop d4 instead of this Bishop d2
move not feared d5 because I think this
is a fine reply yeah there's just
questioning for a second is Knight here
something stopping f4 feels a bit
stranded hmm maybe yeah maybe that is
something I would have to fear
yeah that's that's actually something
because I don't have f4 and now the
threat is here followed up with this and
there's a fork hmm okay maybe I take it
back
all right let's let's see what the
computer has to say right right out of
the gates at least opening wise what are
we working with here it's defense
considered classical variation with the
Knight f3 and I imagine you could play a
lot of different moves here saying h3
and Bishop to e2 as well oh by the way I
don't know why this cross table is
shifted down I don't know
oh you know somebody already clicked a
computer analysis on this one okay it's
still it's still crunching the numbers
there I'll see what the fine there it is
it just finished up that's the final
tally the ACL for each side average
Cynthia Palmas um we'll have a look at
around move 29 30 apparently close to a
pawn advantage for black so just a
normal ish and you could see the the
graph it wasn't anything exciting
evaluation wise until the King and pawn
ending well is it decisive it was within
a pond throughout
until the very end I just had one pawn
it wouldn't be a win but having those
two pawns gave that important tempo
so yeah let's let's have a look at
Bishop d4 is Bishop d4 a good idea it is
not because of d5 and if this Knight h5
is a good reply and now it's tricky I
have to find some accurate moves it I
guess maybe Queen f3 with this in mind
here oh oh oh queen Queen here
interferes with this move because I have
that okay we have to enter some
imbalance so this has to be properly
assessed and I wasn't anywhere close to
assessing this so yeah I went with
something quicker conservative and you
know wanna on a back-and-forth I know I
played it passive towards this ending
here g5 was very aggressive
yeah I went back home Bishop to d2
what's the story after Bishop takes pawn
h4 you know a very computer esque
that it has his points soften up the
King side I still stand better King
safety-wise can I really demonstrate
that that's going to be an advantage I
don't know alright I just hung onto the
b-pawn and I would
to get this sequence in this is a strong
reply Queen c4 so I don't know what do I
do
exchange Queens and live with the fact
that this is a maybe the better Bishop
and many end games if the rooks are
traded I like black space and yeah I
pawn on a light square working well with
this guy this structure would be a
target at some point then again I could
maybe try for this and say yeah I can
fix upon on a dark square for you okay
I'll rely sit still even d4 is in and
now there's there's nothing to really
speak of mmm
except right around here okay hang on
this is where it's a little bit better
for black queen 84 saw that one
what does it like to do here rook a d2
yeah with what in mind Kawena v rook
takes pawn is probably gonna be a
problem right check check and there goes
the rook okay so this guy would be
poison queen f5 queen c1 king h2 Queen
takes b2 and now check here what's the
follow up this and coming for peace
activity yeah some some drawers looking
like but I'd be the one trying to hold
the draw I think I would manage in this
scenario because these pawns are likely
to be exchanged so three versus two on
the Kings side but you never know anyhow
Queen 84 was played oops
queen a 4 B 3 and now it's just even I
went into a complete prevent rook f1 and
now my queen is free to rumble and yeah
even even in this ending even though I'm
up upon black black's pieces keep me
restricted here and there's no great
spot for my rook to get activated took
me a while to realize I needed my Queen
here defending so that I could get my
rep moving and even in here it's a draw
I think black was just looking to win on
time and they were certainly very close
to doing just that
but you know pre moves right here avoid
the Queen exchange I'm probably gonna
lose we have three seconds in the tank
and it's still a draw here but yeah easy
to go wrong
what's the draw here there's only one
drawing move f5 so
let me flick off the engine here what's
the what's the trick Hadiya how do you
draw this as black I believe oh yeah the
here that's interesting because I have I
have a temp on reserved so King g3 the
King steps up here here so even if I use
this temp of the King just constantly
plays to these two and if I try to come
over in this direction no no no this
would be a win for me like it like it
played out in the game so if the King
tries to offset my King on this side of
the pond let's say okay this side of
these relevant pawns this side of the F
pile I'll win so I think black needs to
be in a position to quickly target my
pawns in this way so if I go here
there's this and if I go here there's
that and I'm gonna be losing a pond
right this here now I have to be careful
of not losing
this is maybe instructed I believe the
King needs to again threaten to quickly
approach my pawn like this let's see if
I if I'm correct with this idea so again
only move at this endgame is f5 f5 and
now let's say King g3 okay King f6 yeah
going going here or going here going
here I don't know why you would want to
go backwards but going in this direction
is no good so King u f6 so even king g6
King g6 is off because ah right oh this
is very instructive yeah
King f6 is is saying I'll be really
quick to maybe come over in this
direction possibly so if King f3 and
King e6 so I wasn't correct with saying
he has to always be in a spot to sneak
around this way King III King d5 he had
just one wrong step King D 3 king c5 Wow
a lot of only moves here for black and
so even if I use this tempo then black
plays here takes opposition I go here
here here here here
king c5 diagonal opposition tricky
endgame hmm even with how many seconds
did black have 37 yeah it was maybe
maybe a time to actually think a little
bit here
after that it's it's a winner
throughout isn't it because of this guy
here the all-important tempo pawn
so you could take our position right now
but boom I get it back and fortunately
having just a hunter a second to do it
all okay alright well hopefully I don't
mess up again with the five-o game I
wanted for two but there you have it a
500 game anyhow as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you